про значення польша сама сюди і
перебуваємо ріканського танкова бригада
ваш до техніка в дорозі вже кілька днів і
проїхала через нехай у них чину
американська армія хочу кудись читка
сигнал
підлозі жадібній різниці і занурюють росії
солдати бригад і добрий на тирново не
він і професіонали ось тут би цілий bsx
отриманих штатив
[музика]
багатий американських солдатів of making
одним заповнювалась auf р-н негайно
Петро і ми пара дислокацію близько 4000
солдатів і до Польщі болгарії румунії
the crane балтії та шпинат і фашистів у
нього.
я тьолку в це перука він ще рішення на те
відразу мило і правильні отрута вже добра
знають ситуацію поштою я знаю про страх
людей особливо його переслідування за зовнішньою
політики Росії зал стане жирів і так
їх як наприклад
анексія криму та інших по 20 з тенге
не алексу нікому на внутрішнє рішення
посилає і позиції натомість на сході у хвали
ваще в 2014 у
2017 у он у духу актуально німецька
політик з turbo ванілі точністю
прогресу на жаль вирішення конфлікту мід
Росії то україни і за конфлікт Москви
все конфлікт неопренові вирішить і колишній
повія тис. далі я багата про позитиві
нашого міністра закордонних
довідки-рахунки контролю над оружням
читаєш і мови близнюки не довели до
цілі та наріжте патча труби тут шукаєте
кого перерахунок та добро б думати on tour
води і загинули в цій сумці ми хочемо
осп брати з росії you all a за 1 wan
про дату а я готова спробувати
вона тупо рикуна не став вами альянсу до
Росії не зміните на прес
емпатії нового президента США до
господаря кремля